Digital content usage is growing rapidly
Developers must constantly search for ways
To achieve the physical income of their product hold
In providing a distinct user experience
In Viki, the subscriptions helped us
To enhance and develop our business
The subscriber base is growing almost 3 times per year
The availability of contributions was easier than we expected
My name is "Alex Chan"
I am a Senior Vice President of Products & Engineering
In Viki, a group company Rakuten
We provide a global platform for entertainment video
Focusing mainly on the content of Asia, both television programs
Or movies, with the support of our dedicated fan community
We started work 6 years ago
A business model is based on advertising for material income
We wanted to increase the chances of receiving profits
And provide better use experiences for our service users
So we launched the subscription feature through Google Play
3 years ago
It was very easy
It only requires a few lines of code to take care of
Payment APIs with the rest of the tasks
Subscription earnings increased by
More than 200% last year
We were impressed by the other positive results
After launching the service
Android vogue helped us in emerging markets and open platforms
To succeed. Use a credit card
Limited in these countries
But make payments available through Google Play
For example through gift cards and carrier billing
Payment processes facilitate users in these markets
The growth rate of our subscribers was from emerging markets
Such as Latin America and the Middle East, exceeds 700% each year
Subscriptions and Google Play invoices
Help us expand the base of our service users who share a fee
Around the world and earning new profits from emerging markets
We currently offer our special offers
We support an active community of millions of users viewing content in more than 200 languages
Most importantly, our fans have expressed to us
How important our product and content are to entertain themselves and learn new cultures
This kind of effect is
Evidence of our success at work.